une catherine vous le sachiez l'a fait
dix ans de basket philippe disant ouais
c'est un très grand champion de basket
un non professionnel je précise web etc
torrent a fait dix ans de basket et je
t'ai vu un petit peu joué à la pub je
peux vous dire que c'est quelqu'un sait
quelque chose il faut pas le faire chier
de philippe katerine selon philippe on
va faire un petit jeu il ya quatre
ballons on va faire ce qu'on appelle un
basket confession c'est à dire que on va
devoir mettre le ballon dans le panier
si on ne met pas tous les deux on doit
faire une confession la première
confession c'est si tu devais coucher
avec quelqu'un du métier du même sexe ce
serait qui si tu le mets valoir des gens
décédés
oui bien sûr je pense à isabelle saporta
alors je vais te le dis donc si tu le
mets c'est bon pour toi t'as pas à
donner ta confiance auprès d'accor si tu
ne le met pas bien sûr tu donnes et à
confessions ces essais par hape l'ombre
si on ne met pas tous les deux on doit
dire tous les d'accord attention des
gens de même sexe est ce que tu veux
commencer oui si tu veux ces particules
ce ballon où tu veux ton ballon et tu es
tu t'entraînes est que celui-là dont il
pas mieux sur et ballons jaunes moi
c'est pas trop mon affaire allez vas-y
fais comme tu veux pas ça fait beaucoup
de bruit quand vous faites bien
attention valleyfield alors patienter
pas ta soeur
attention féloche il va devoir faire ça
contre est sûre c'est sur coma son
masque est à temps ouais ouais patrick
pierrick mary quant au taux de 3,2 hors
de droite je dois faire ma confession
aussi donc si tu devais coucher avec une
personne de même sexe du métier ce
serait qui a du métier
oui bien qu'on exclut les du même sexe
des hommes politiques si tu peux aussi
le plan politique tu peux aussi basique
pas de quelqu'un peut être pas le même
métier moi quelqu'un de connu quelqu'un
de connu je dirais peut-être
mais c'est pour ça que je pensais à
quelqu'un de confortables et moi de
jean-raymond baroud raymond barre a oui
mais il est non t'as pas quelque chose
donc moi bellechasse jamais droit aux
gens des cités oui oui mais oui mais
confortable et quelqu'un de vivant dans
le même registre d'un philippe seguin
moi en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est pas benjamin griveaux d'acier sur
moi ça serait castaldi bardon a cédé
dans le jeu c'est que je souris derrière
les tables rcs le castillan plus je
laissais mon ami c'est mon frère
ça fait peur mais j'ai très content
parce que c'est qu'il doit vous allez
dormir ensemble ouais ouais bah bien sur
wii en temps mais en cuillère oculaire
et toi fais avec ses joues bien qui
finit le dernier verre de giverny
ah ouais ça va faire plaisir à pas tout
ça tu vas prendre deux semaines de plata
attention philippe offert d'un petit
deuxième ballon confession a dit john
paul jones se sent mieux pour toi
et
allez me dire ça va c'est bon tu n'auras
pas confessé il fallait lire le dernier
sms tout avait reçu tétreault qui ma
mère à ta mère bon bah ça va ça va c'est
vite dit voilà bah je vais dire le
dernier sms que j'ai reçu c'est valérie
bénaïm je crois que c'est dépêche toi
connard on va être à l'antenne je crois
que c'est ça le haut niveau
ouais je crois que c'est ça non annoncés
agatha roulons les deux enquêtes du
début dans l'ordre que tu veux jean
michel est quelqu'un d'autre c'est pas
le grand amour c'est pour l'émission de
ce soir c'est voilà philippe katerine
bravo est ce que tu vas faire une
dynamique
oui si tu veut avaler alors je vais déjà
coché une dernière confession temps sur
dernières confessions là si tu perds
away confessé le nombre de partenaires
sexuels que vous avez eue hollande
attention à l'est
est de dix ans de basket lisons de
basket oh mon dieu non non non non
malheureusement c'est non et qu'on sait
non c'est non je tire à hue alors vas-y
philippe tu vas me le diront partons
basé sur les doigts d'une main
trois jours c'est vrai c'est vrai tu as
connu des femmes à quel âge bien nous
mars un peu pas merci les pommes bien
beau mais on a faim c'est quoi combien
d'ados demain avec sur les boîtes noires
c'est sur les doigts d'une main bah moi
tu me suis hissé sur les doigts de ddd
pied non sur les orteils en fait une
quinzaine en quinzaine